(upbeat music)
[Derek] Hey Rob, This is
Derek from Chico, California,
and I love the pod.
One thing I don't think
you've talked about much is
where you've traveled in your
life, not that I recall anyway
What is the most
unexpectedly wonderful place
you've ever traveled to in the world,
and where would you like to
go that you haven't been?
Thanks for answering.
Thank you, Derek for
calling, the Lowe Down Line.
I don't know how unexpected
it is, but without a doubt
the place that when I landed
there and looked at it,
I was just moved almost tears by,
was the Island of Bora Bora.
It is absolutely magical beyond belief.
The other place was surprising
because you hear about Yosemite,
I live in California,
I've lived, You're in Chico,
you're in California as well
and I finally got to Yosemite
and I came around the corner
and looked at that
Yosemite Valley and my eyes
just spilled over with tears.
It is, the Yosemite Valley,
if you traveled across
the world to get there,
you wouldn't have been disappointed
and yet it's right in my state
and I'd never gotten there.
Just beyond spectacular.
Where would I like to go?
Well, you know where I wanna go?
I wanna go to Japan, to ski.
That's what I wanna do.
There's and I should know
the name of it, but I don't,
but there's a resort on,
I think it's the Island of Hokkaido,
I hope I'm pronouncing it right,
that has the most powder
of anywhere in the world
and skiing connoisseurs know
that that is the place you go for powder.
So the notion of having like
amazing authentic Japanese food
and powdered ski every
day is next literally,
next on my bucket list.
(upbeat music)